if you're like me you finished june 1984
or even the 2021 version which i haven't
seen yet and we're like that's it that's
it so what happens next spoiler warning
for those who haven't seen the movie
paul atreides aka muadeeb becomes
emperor and takes control of arrakis but
there are five other novels after which
continue the dune saga and it just so
happens there's a three-part mini-series
from 2003 starring james mcavoy and
susan sarandon which continues this
story so if you're curious what happens
next this video is for you but if you
don't know anything about dune i suggest
you check out my dune 1984 video which
i'll leave a link to in the description
below but without further ado make sure
to like and subscribe because we're
taking a trip to arrakis children of
dune takes place 12 years after the
death of emperor shadom the dude who
conspired against house atreides in dune
the mini-series itself encompasses two
of frank herbert's sequel novels dune
messiah and children of dune so that's
what we'll be covering today paula
tradies who simply goes by the name
muadeeb i'll be using both of those
names interchangeably has begun his
crusade of colonizing the imperium
planets one by one any who refuse will
be executed to put things in perspective
60 billion people have died in this
crusade but because muadeeb can see into
the future he knows that this isn't the
worst possible outcome for humanity if
however he wants the best path for
humanity he must follow what's called
the golden path but we'll get to that in
a bit muadeeb rules from the empire's
new capital the desert planet arrakis
also known as doon because of his
control over the spice planet he has a
complete monopoly over spice production
the most valuable commodity in the known
universe and this monopoly does not sit
well with many of the emperor's enemies
but something is eating away at muadeeb
he hasn't yet been able to produce an
heir with his lover chani and the
religious zealotry of his followers has
started to get out of hand now you might
be asking yourself why aren't muadeeb
and chani married well in an effort to
ease tensions within the various houses
of the empire mouri marries princess
ireland carino the daughter of former
emperor shaddam it seems to be a
marriage entitle only as muadeeb's real
love has always been chaney one of the
main antagonists of children of dune is
princess winsocya currino daughter of
emperor shadom and his sister ireland
her father's grip on the empire is no
more and her house has effectively lost
most of its power so she devises a plan
to undermine paul by creating what's
called a gola of his old friend duncan
idaho who died in the original dune a
gola is an artificially created human
almost like a clone but a gola can
possess memories of the past the hope
here is that this gola can be
manipulated to assassinate paul at the
same time multiple plots against muadib
and his family make life on dune a
dangerous affair we find out someone has
been poisoning chani so that she can't
conceive princess when cecilia has
stolen a sand worm in an attempt to make
spice on her own planet of seleusa
secundus and a terrorist attack against
muadib leaves him blinded but even
though he is blinded he is still able to
see with his powers they blinded my body
but not my vision for their own safety
muadeeb takes chany who was able to
conceive to the safety of the desert
there she gives birth to twins but dies
in the process at this point muadeeb who
had meddled in what he called impossible
futures still ends up in a scenario
where the woman he loves dies so he goes
off into the desert to die alone it is
only then that he considers himself
truly free but that's not where the
story ends in fact the majority of
children of dune revolves around paul's
two children lato the second named after
the duke and gonima the story advances
several years with lado just six months
away from being of age to take control
of the empire since then their aunt alia
who you may remember as the blue-eyed
girl from the original dune has been
holding power as regent she ended up
orchestrating the death of the reverend
mother moaim and the guild navigator
edric right around the time of muadeeb's
disappearance but since then a lot has
changed alia has grown a cult of
personality around herself and the
rituals and myths surrounding muhaddib
have become perverted she has turned
much of arrakis's spice sands into green
pastures limiting the amount of spice
production and thus driving up demand it
has gotten so bad that a rebel group of
fremen have challenged alia's powers
which could turn the entire planet into
an all-out civil war and to make matters
worse alia has turned abomination in the
dune universe this refers to when one
becomes psychologically unstable and
this manifests in alia when she is
haunted by voices particularly that of
her grandfather vladimir harkinan i
don't think this is mentioned in the
1984 version but lady jessica is the
illegitimate daughter of vladimir
harkinan making alia his granddaughter
speaking of lady jessica she returns to
arrakis after years off planet doomed to
her brings back too many painful
memories after all both her husband and
son died there this has caused
resentment in alia who feels her mother
abandoned her you mix all this together
along with some assassination attempts
and alia becomes much like a mad king
ordering extermination of various
feminine rebel groups and building
suspicion that her niece and nephew may
usurp her power we're also introduced to
a character known as the preacher which
the mini-series does a very bad job of
hiding the fact that he is actually
muadeeb returned he isn't too happy how
his name has been used to justify a lot
of the bad [ __ ] going on and with things
hitting a fever pitch lady jessica
denounces alia in front of the people
and another assassination attempt occurs
which causes complete pandemonium
throughout the palace lato and ganyman
make it to the desert where they are
chased down by two laza tigers sent by
princess wencesia this is all part of
the princess's plan to regain control of
the empire if the tradies twins are
killed and alias it comes to madness she
may have a shot of regaining power lado
however fakes his death and his sister
believes him to have died by one of
these tigers this is all part of lato's
plan to follow what is known as the
golden path by following the golden path
lato could prevent humanity's own
destruction for paul the path was so
arduous that he left it to live alone in
the desert because he could see the
future he knew the drastic measures he
would have had to take in order for
humanity to avoid annihilation and that
was just too much for him his son lato
on the other hand embraced the golden
path on his journey he stumbles upon a
smuggler's den where san trout are sold
off world to the highest bidder santrout
are basically baby sand worms who over
the course of thousands of years turn
into these giant sandworms we see on
dune lado ends up allowing the sand
worms to attach themselves to his body
which begins a process of transformation
affording him super human-like abilities
even greater than what he already has
this gives him super speed agility and
strength alia believing her nephew to be
dead and with enemies around her at
every turn agrees to a political
marriage of convenience between ganima
and princess winsosya's son faradan this
was an arrangement designed behind
alia's back by duncan idaho in the book
these two are married but the
mini-series portrays them as lovers
duncan will later kill alia's lover
javid in the neutral territory of
sichthabar essentially forcing stilgar
who up to this point was neutral to join
the war against alia you see once ali
would find out her lover was killed on
this neutral territory she'd attack
stilgar's fremen tribe in retaliation at
the same time lato finds his father in
the desert up until this point he had
only seen his father in dreams lato
tells him he wishes to make a future
free of one man's vision free of a
future that is predetermined and he
hopes with himself at the helm he can do
this so he ventures back to era keen to
seize control from his crazy aunt at the
capitol princess winsocia arrives with
her son for the marriage between him and
ganyman ganima earlier told ireland that
she hates this marriage and will kill
faradan on their wedding night but
something completely unexpected happens
here something the mini-series doesn't
do a particularly good job at probably
because they simply didn't have enough
time faraday betrays his mother and
openly tells him that it was his mom who
was responsible for assassinating lato
remember they still think he died from
that tiger this betrayal was spurred by
years of abuse ferran received from his
mother who thought he was weak and would
never be a man it's only after this
betrayal and the princess is banished
that she finally sees him as a man
you're more of a man than i ever thought
possible fraud tells ganima this is her
wedding present how cute muadeeb returns
to arakin and causes a stir as a crowd
forms around him he believes that one
blasphemy remains and that is alia
sensing this preacher is her brother
alia hides herself among the crowd only
to be discovered by him it's only a
brief moment before a fremen assassin
kills muadeeb later arrives and holds
his father in his hands as the two
disappear into the sand we then
awkwardly transition to the wedding
which seems to be going on even after
this big event lato interrupts the
service to put an end to alia once and
for all to reach humanity of the
perversions done in wardeeb's name
and to save it from the abomination
known as aliyah we get to see lato's
proficiency in the weirding way this
close hand-to-hand comet that allows him
to teleport around and make quick work
of alia's guards aliyah then joins the
fight but isn't strong enough to take
down her nephew he ultimately gives her
the opportunity to kill him as the voice
of baron harkin yells at her to finish
him but aliyah breaks free of these
voices and ultimately chooses to kill
herself thus ending her reign of terror
lady jessica leaves dune while gurney
and ireland stay lato returns to stilgar
with alia's water and asks him to spread
it among the sand think of it as the
fremen way of spreading ashes he also
gives him his father's signet ring that
once belonged to both paul and lato the
first it's a sign that all humans make
mistakes not mentioned in the
mini-series but lato ends up as emperor
marrying his sister to consolidate power
but this is purely a political move and
the two never consummate their marriage
ganima ends up having children with
feron her concubine that's where the
children of dune mini-series ends
however there are three more novels
after this but as far as i know no big
budget shows or films that cover them
i'm hoping to cover the new dune movie
when it hits theaters later this month
so be sure to like and subscribe and
stick around for that thanks for
watching everyone for more bad takes you
can follow me on twitter and instagram
at thinkstoryyt until next time remember
daddy loves you very much
[Music]